we know the chancellor is talking about
the impact on the UK economy but what we
care about is the impact on UK
households we woke this morning to some
good news for householders which is that
the energy price guarantee is indeed
going to be Frozen at the current level
of 2 500 pounds for another three months
Energy prices has a sword over the last
few months as we all know we were
expecting until that was confirmed that
energy price guarantee would rise it now
will not rise and indeed most analysts
are now predicting that by the middle of
this year July onwards Energy prices
will fall still further so Energy prices
good news for households
more uncertainty about income tax now
while we're not expecting to see any
rise in the headline rates of income tax
we do know that that average rate of tax
the effective rate of tax that we all
pay has increased over the last few
years and in Nest the government today
unless the chancellor unfreezes income
tax thresholds this is effectively a
sort of stealth tax if income tax
thresholds stay constant even though
earnings or increases we're all paying
effectively a bit more tax so Working
Families people on uh incomes especially
higher incomes will be watching to see
very closely about income tax thresholds
now those are lower incomes and depend
on government support have other things
to worry about and in particular they'll
be looking to see whether the rate of
Universal Credit increases in line with
inflation whether disability living
allowance or personal Independence
payments increases in line with
inflation and whether we see the winter
fuel payment continue so again very big
difference depending on your income
level and your household composition
during the course of today we are going
to be talking to a number of
householders around the UK to understand
what the budget means for them and we're
going to be looking in detail at those
households that let's have a look at
Leanne so Leanne is a self-employed mum
she has a four-year-old daughter her
daughter too old to benefit from the
additional child care support that's
been rumored over the last day or two
that might we might see at lunchtime
Linda Linda is a retired occupational
therapist while Linda's husband does
work Linda is dependent on pension and
disability support so she'll be looking
to see whether those numbers increase in
today's announcement
and Mike an I.T consultant Mike owns
well but as a householder he like all of
us has faced those higher energy prices
higher costs of food and fuel and
everything else squeezing his wallet so
what does this mean today for a working
person like Mike and other households
over the course of today we'll be doing
live analysis on these particular
household finances and how the budget
affects them and we'll also be going
live to them to get their reaction